speaking of the tax plan you know that
phrase the enemy of my enemy is my
friend I've never been huge on that and
I have an example here that we can think
about to see if it makes any sense and
for the most part I'm sure you know that
Fox News and its dysfunctional sibling
the Fox Business Network loved Trump
they generally love Trump's tax plan a
fox business hosts stuart varney
recently debated a quote patriotic
millionaire who we actually might
interview when we get back from the New
Year's break and argued that it's just a
fantastic tax plan it's a fair plan it's
all great not everybody at Fox Business
loves it Fox Business host trish regan
is increasingly openly hostile to the
bill but sort of for a lot of the wrong
reasons let's listen to what she had to
say about it yes i love the idea of
lower corporate taxes but i really do
not like what they're doing on the
individual side and my concern here is
it's gonna hurt the individual and so
effectively individuals are carrying the
water for these corporations they get
that great tax cut but mcore Peretz ID
but people are not going to get it on
the individual side and i just don't
think that's fair because look at what
the president have been promising
everyone basically oh yeah we will lower
the rates very very substantially for
virtually everybody in every category
including i hope some of the democrats
that are going to lose their election
will come over and give everybody a big
beautiful tax cut which is going to be
great for the economy we're going to
give the American people a huge tax cut
for Christmas hopefully that will be a
great big beautiful Christmas present I
think it's gonna be much of a presence
so what getting coal in your stocking
here cuz your tax bill is gonna go up so
what are the chances that maybe the
House and Senate just put aside the
individual plan right now and just focus
on the corporate well I guess they can't
do that because of reconciliation yeah
it's not gonna happen but so so she's
against the bill but she wants to lower
corporate taxes why I mean first of all
the effective corporate tax rate in the
US is really low people like Trump say
the most taxed businesses blah blah blah
the the paper rate is actually not that
high and the effective rate is even
lower and secondly from an economic
standpoint lowering corporate taxes
doesn't encourage investment in the
business it encourages taking profits at
a new lower tax rate and corporate CEOs
were actually asked would you hire more
people if the corporate tax rate were
lower and overwhelmingly they said no we
won't which is obvious because a lower
corporate tax rate means you can keep
profits and pay a lower rate
you're not gonna hire workers because
they lower your tax rate you would hire
workers if more people are buying your
product or service or if demand growth
goes up for what you're producing and
then Trish Regan says she doesn't like
what's happening with the individual tax
rates because everyone was promised a
tax cut and not everyone will get one
again yes
pointing out Trump's hypocrisy is good
he said everyone gets a tax cut turns
out taxes will actually go up in the
long term for more than half of all
Americans but even if everyone got a tax
cut the important thing is why are we
giving the lion's share of the tax cuts
to the very rich so she's against the
bill on those for those reasons and then
she actually even grew her assault and
here she's actually bringing me more
over to her side this time she goes
after the tax cuts for the super-rich
the house is gonna be voting on the
final tax bill tomorrow afternoon the
president keeps touting this is the
biggest tax cut ever and while it's
great for corporations and there's
nothing wrong with that
and it's also great for a lot of fat-cat
private equity investors it's and
there's something wrong with that this
guy Steve Schwarzman who's made over 400
million dollars in one year and
percentage-wise well guess what his tax
bracket is actually lower than a new
york city cop car you like that and it's
because he calls his income investment
the president promised to fix this
remember we will eliminate the carried
interest deduction well known deduction
and other special interest loopholes
that have been so good for Wall Street
investors and for people like me okay so
listen we have some points of agreement
yes she's delivering this critique
number one on some points that I don't
agree with her
number two in a sort of weird Mushmouth
way maybe it's an awkward teleprompter
read I don't know what's going on but I
think beggars can't be choosers Pat and
if we have someone at fox business that
is actually against the bill then we
should say hey here's someone who's
against the bill even if it's not for
all the reasons we're against the bill
yeah you have a few points of agreement
with her I understand that and I think
she's gonna be fired pretty soon out hey
Shep Smith is still at Fox and he's the
occasional voice of reason Chris Wallace
an occasional voice of reason at Fox
he's still there everyone else has been
ousted for sexual misconduct yeah
they've left you Yuri that's that's a
good one people the people at Fox are
gone but it has nothing to do with their
political views it's sexual misconduct
so I think that this is good also if it
gets the the Fox News audience to turn
on itself that's always good because
those internal battles are usually
pretty good for people who are on a
different side altogether so Trish Regan
I think she's way off on the corporate
tax rate but in this case the enemy of
my enemy is my friend and I would love
to interview her on the program and find
out more about her economic views you
can discuss this and anything else from
today's show on our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash read it today's episode
of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
one in need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial dot-com /t DPS